if electric cars are the future then
luxury electric cars are the future of
luxury
right
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and i
spent a day with a completely unreleased
future electric car called the lucid air
and the team behind it to take the
closest look at it yet and just to learn
what the deal is with this car and the
future of electric cars and i learned a
lot now we're already familiar with
tesla and what they make and how that
works you can check out my videos about
them if you haven't already lucid air
claims to be in a lot of ways kind of
similar to that but with a few tricks up
its sleeve so the exterior is pretty
familiar all the way from the miniature
size mock-ups all the way to the
life-size one-to-one clay models they
showed me it has its own unique look you
could say it's not a hatchback so it
looks a lot more like a big sedan than a
crossover and they do their best to look
a little more modern nothing too extreme
but it's a little sleeker the mirrors on
the the sides are a little smaller a
little sleeker looking the low profile
wheels kind of remind me of the bmw i8
the door handles are completely embedded
in the doors with push to unlock and
there's extra lights around here and
there even bar headlights and tail
lights one of the most eye-catching
features actually from the promo video
those headlights groundbreaking
technology
we're actually not motorized in the
prototype that we got to use which made
me sad basically i can only cross my
fingers that who knows maybe it'll
actually make it to the final version
but the exterior as clean as it is is
definitely not the reason people are
interested in the lucid air that would
be the interior one of the biggest
complaints with tesla actually is the
interior just doesn't feel
luxury enough for some people i mean it
was never a problem for me but the other
people coming from you know bmws and
high-end mercedes and porsches were
actually kind of disappointed with the
interior of the tesla and pointed at
that as being one of the biggest flaws
for the price lucid air is really
attacking that luxury feel 100 they're
going all out with material choices the
layout of the displays the look and feel
of everything to overall make the
experience of sitting in the car
especially in the back seat as dope as
possible so first of all inside as the
driver up front naturally you have a lot
of control at your fingertips so as soon
as you sit in the driver's seat you have
three displays surrounding you a touch
screen all the way up to the left with a
bunch of vehicle controls the heads-up
display right behind the steering wheel
with the most important information like
your speed and the battery percentage or
maybe possibly the most beautiful
charging indicator status i've ever seen
and then another touch screen to the
right of that with smart systems things
like navigation and contacts etc it kind
of makes sense that a high-tech vehicle
from the future has this many pixels
laid out in front of you but they seem
smartly laid out and they have the
features that are sort of complementing
each other in the right spots in the car
and on top of all that there's another
touch screen a center console where you
can display navigation info and
third-party apps and all kinds of stuff
like that but it's a little down and out
of the way so you can hide it at any
time with a push of a button that
actually reveals more center storage so
it seems to be a pretty solid balance
between physical controls and touch
screen controls for things that you do
with the vehicle every day from the
front seat and then the second thing
you'll notice as a driver or anyone in
the front seat is the windshield it is
awesome it reminds me of what tesla did
with the model x the glass stretches
basically from the hood right up all the
way over your head to behind you so it's
just one big pane of glass there's just
light flooding in and you can see
everything it's kind of how the lucid
air got its name it creates a very open
airy experience where you can see all
around you and i guarantee that when
this car is driving itself in a couple
of years it'll be that much cooler just
looking around it'll be a lot of fun to
be a passenger but there are some
differences between this and the model x
first off is that t column down the
middle that you can see that holds an
led light strip it's the ambient light
and the rear view mirror and the sun
shades and a second thing a switch for
the electrochromic shading that will
tint the ceiling from nearly transparent
all the way to almost completely opaque
now unfortunately this is also still in
development and they couldn't show it to
me working but it seems to me that that
would be really cool and also really
expensive if you ever got a crack in
your windshield but either way it's
awesome to be able to look up at any
time and the weight is transparent you
can see you know not just the clouds but
even skyscrapers when you're going
through the city or the stars at night
since it's completely clear really cool
stuff to be sitting in the front seat of
this car
and then you get to the back seat and
that is where it gets real the back seat
of the lucid air is these jet like
bucket seats with tons of legroom and
headroom with all that glass over your
head still it just keeps sweeping back
and the premium materials and the arm
rest and vents are all still there you
even get your own little console in the
middle with climate control and seat
recline controls and on top of that this
isn't just your average seat back
recline this is like you're not gonna
want to call shotgun in this car you're
gonna want to sit in the back seat these
back seats recline way back so so far
back it kind of feels like a lie flat on
an airplane when you're all the way back
you're just kind of looking up at a
clear pane of glass so you can sit back
and basically just stare at the sky for
a long car ride as a passenger that
definitely feels like the future the
biggest sacrifice for the seats this far
back is definitely the trunk space for
the size of the car and all its
advantages and maybe has one of the
smaller trunks i've ever seen in a large
sedan but lucid also does have a regular
bench back seat version of this car that
feels a little less luxury but gets a
lot of the trunk space back so you know
a little bit of a fair trade there
that'll probably sell a lot more in the
u.s and there's also a sizable front
trunk in this car that's a lot bigger
actually than the one that's in the
tesla as well so there's a lot of cool
stuff going on for the lucid air as an
idea and as a product uh the fact that
this company lucid motors exists and is
making a statement like trying to make a
product like this is really interesting
to me whether it actually comes out or
not it sheds a lot of light on what it
looks like people are going to want from
a car in the future which doesn't just
have to be a good driving car but also
has to be a good ride sharing car and a
good self-driving car etc so it's silent
huge spacious open airy high-tech and oh
by the way happens to have a thousand
horsepower and ridiculous performance
because electric cars can do that nice
so what do you think is this the future
of luxury i know i'm not against it and
i'm definitely rooting for companies
like this to succeed to be able to
provide competition and make what we
already have get better so let me know
what you guys think of the air thanks
for watching this one and i'll talk to
you guys the next one
peace
[Music]